my talk at the table is Michelle Obama
on Friday I got to moderate a
conversation in Philadelphia Friday
night about a new book it's called the
light we carry the light we carry is a
former first lady's second book it talks
about coping with adversity it deals
with topics like Prejudice the pandemic
and the future of our country in Mrs
Obama's words the goal is to give
readers a glimpse inside my personal
toolkit or the strategy she uses to be
more comfortable less paralyzed inside
of uncertainty so we had a great
conversation on stage we chatted behind
the scenes before going on stage
[Music]
accepting who they are yeah I would have
worn braids but you know in the White
House the White House but they freaked
out when I got bangs you know it's just
and you've got banged remember that when
I go when I left my Banks yes oh that
was a story it's about the bangs it's
like what does it mean why is she
changing her hair and it's like okay
good good it's right before becoming you
said I was really nervous about it
coming out yeah yeah you don't feel that
this time do you I do there's still the
initial kind of still you know that that
you know caution about putting yourself
out there are you aware of how many
books uh becoming sold Mrs yeah
and then shortly after the appearance
she gave me a jacket as a thank you all
the moderators got these I love anything
with my initials on it but when I I
really do I'm still 12 when it comes to
that male or GK I like it but when I
greeted her with that hey buddy in her
book she's got a great chapter about
starting kind and she talks about a
friend of hers a grown man who every
morning looks at himself in the mirror
and says hey buddy how you doing I tried
doing that I felt goofy doing it but I
think it's such a good thing for people
to start kind with yourself and a whole
chapter about you know when they go low
we go high I said a lot of people going
how high does how long do we have to say
hi Obama right does she still believe
that yes she's definitely does she
definitely does that's awesome great
conversation you guys are talking about
everything including hair yep yep we're
glad to see her yes including hair
that's awesome that was good stuff